in the last video we had this second
order linear homogeneous differential
equation we just tried out the solution
y is equal e to the rx and we got uh we
figured out that if you try that out
then it works for particular r's and
those are as we figure out the last one
were minus two and minus three but it
came out of factoring this
characteristic equation and watched the
last video if you forgot how we got that
characteristic equation and we ended up
with this general solution for this
differential equation and you could try
it out if you don't believe me that it
works but what if we have we don't want
the general solution we want to find the
particular solution well then we need
initial condition so let's let's use
let's do this differential equation with
some
initial condition so let's say the
initial conditions
are let's say let me scroll this down we
have the solution
that we figured out in the last video
let me rewrite the differential equation
so it was the second derivative
the second derivative
plus five times the first derivative
plus six
times the function
is equal to zero and the initial
conditions we're given is that y
of 0
is equal to 2
and the first derivative at 0 or y prime
at 0
is equal to 3. so they're giving us what
does y equal at the point 0 and what is
the slope and this at 0 at x is equal to
0 and the slope is 3. so how do we use
these to solve for c1 and c2
well
let's just use the first initial
condition y of 0 is equal to 2.
so y of 0 so y
of 0 is equal to 2 which is equal to
essentially just substitute 0 in into
this equation
so it's c1
times e to the minus 2 times 0 what's e
to the that's essentially e to the 0
right so that's just 1. so it's c1 times
1 which is a c1
plus
c2 times e to the minus 3 times 0 this
is e to the 0 so it's just 1 so plus c2
so the first equation we get when we
substitute our first initial condition
is essentially c one plus c two is equal
to two
now let's apply our second initial
condition that tells us the slope at x
is equal to zero so y prime of zero so
this is our general solution let's take
its derivative and then we can use this
so y prime of x
y prime of x is equal to what
the derivative of this
is equal to minus 2
minus 2
c 1
times e to the minus 2 x
and what's the derivative of this it's
minus
c 2
times e to the minus 3
x
and now we can use our initial condition
y prime at 0. so when x is equal to 0
what's the right hand side equal it's
minus
2 times c 1 and then e to the minus 0 e
to the zero so that's just one
minus three
c two and then once again x is zero so e
to the minus three times zero that's
just one so it's just one times minus
three c two and it tells us that when x
is equal to zero what is this whole
derivative equal well that equals three
right y prime of zero is equal to three
so now we go back into your first year
of algebra we have two equations two
linear equations with two unknowns and
we could solve let me write them in a
form that you're probably more used to
so the first one is
c one plus c two
is equal to two
and the second one is
minus 2
c1
minus 3
c2
is equal to 3
is equal to 3.
so what can we do let's multiply this
top equation by 2.
there's a ton of ways to solve this but
if you multiply the top equation times 2
you'll get i'll do this in a different
color just so it's changed i'm just
multiplying the top 1 by 2 you get 2 c1
plus 2 c2 is equal to four
and now we can add these two equations
let's see minus two c one plus two those
cancel out so minus three plus two you
get minus
c two
is equal to
seven
or we could say that
c2
is equal to -7
and now we can substitute back in here
we have
c1 plus c2 c2 is -7 so minus 7
is equal to
or
we know that
see oh sorry no i'm already confusing
myself my brain was getting ahead of
myself c1 plus 2 c2 that's -7 is equal
to 2 right i'm just substituting back to
this differential equation assigned to
this equation not a differential it's
just a simple linear equation and then
we get c1 is equal to
9.
and now we have our particular solution
to the differential equation so this was
our general solution we can just
substitute our c1s and our c2s back in
we have our particular solution for
those initial conditions and i think
that warrants a different color so our
particular solution is
y of x
is equal to c1 which we figured out is
e
to the minus 2x
plus c2 well c2 is -7 minus 7
e
to the minus 3x
that is the particular solution to our
original differential equation and it
might be a good exercise for you to
actually test it out this particular
solution to this differential equation
i'll do another example in the next
video i'll see you soon